alors vous venez passer des vacances en
zambie
laissez moi deviner vous venez de l est
new york alors monsieur conrad ne se
joint pas nous ce soir
il ya deux jours il m'a annoncé qu'il
voulait divorcer il y a deux heures je
suis arrivé dans cet hôtel où je vais
passer notre deuxième lune de miel en
célibataire les gens viennent souvent se
perdre ici pour retrouver leur chemin
merci beaucoup iata voici fopac
excursions oui des récollets stone si
vous voulez vous plaindre à mes
supérieurs à 7 les pilotes on survole la
plus grande réserve du continent
accrochez vous bien à se poser quelques
minutes mais où est ce qu'on va se poser
j'étais dans l'avion s'il vous plaît je
vais revenir
e
[Musique]
les braconniers ils ont tué la mère pour
couper ses défenses si on n'aide pas
c'est éléphanteaux il sera mort dans
deux jours je veux rester avec lui sa
maman c'est bien pour safari tiens j'ai
fait un petit détour est ce qui n'est
pas s'en sortir
il est dans un état critique mais on va
faire de notre mieux je suis dans une
réserve
entouré par des animaux sauvages bien
new york je suis désolé je rentrais
rassure moi
cette année on va passer à noël afrique
c'est quoi un noël africain je ne sais
pas si ça se passe comme ça sur tout le
continent mais ici à l'orphelinat for
éléphants les festivités durent toute la
semaine et on ne fait pas le moindre
achat
je commence vraiment à m'inquiéter je
vais rentrer chez moi je ne sais pas ce
que je suis censé faire de ma vie
qu'est ce que vous faites ici
c'est comme ça que ça commence vous
rencontrez un éléphant et vous avez un
ami pour la vie
prenez soin de mon éléphant notre et
l'effort et d eric ligne aérienne entre
nous on est amis rien de plus puisque
vous partez sans avoir eu droit à votre
fabuleux safari 5 étoiles j'aimerais
vous emmener en ferrain ce sera moins
luxueux aux gars des toiles 3 ils ont
plutôt aux deux ça faisait longtemps que
tu n'avais pas ouvert ton coeur si j'ai
appris quelque chose ici c'est qu'il ne
faut jamais trop s'attacher
je n'avais vraiment pas prévu de rester
aussi longtemps d'être tombée amoureuse
de l'afrique ça alors quoi sédhiou ou
non ça c'est pas dit où la pente est
trop si c'est ce qu'on appelle du ou
africains
[Musique]